[LOGO]
I'm really excited to announce
our last, but absolutely
not the least, keynote speakers,
Roger Peng and Hilary Parker,
the hosts of Not So
Standard Deviations.
[APPLAUSE]
If you've never
heard of it before,
really fantastic podcast.
They've never invited me
to be a guest speaker,
but fortunately, I'm not
bitter about that at all.
[LAUGHTER]
But seriously, a very long
time fan of Roger and Hilary.
Roger has been a supporter
of the Tidyverse,
really before it
was the Tidyverse.
And I think his use
of our 2018 keynote
does a better job of
kind of articulating
the philosophy and the
benefits of the Tidyverse
than I've ever managed.
I'm also very fortunate
to call Hilary a friend.
Hilary is a fantastic
data scientist.
I've had a number of really
insightful conversations
with her.
One recent one, which led me
to really understand, like,
one of the things
that I do is design.
But as well as being a data
scientist at Stitch Fix,
Hilary--
I'm also very lucky that
Hilary has acted as my stylist.
And she actually just picked out
the clothes I'm wearing today.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
So I'd like you
to please join me
in welcoming Hilary and Roger.
[APPLAUSE]
OK, so you're going to get
a little behind the scenes
action here, because the
listeners of our show
don't see this, but we
have to do this every time.
You know when you're dealing
in a high stakes situation
like this, safety comes first.
Yeah.
So we have a checklist that
we go through every time.
So we're going to go
through the checklist.
OK, Hilary, hard wired?
ROGER PENG: I guess we
don't really need that.
VPN turned off?
HILARY PARKER: Yeah.
My work VPN causes
problems with our--
ROGER PENG: A number
of problems, yes.
HILARY PARKER: --connections.
ROGER PENG: Wi-Fi turned off?
HILARY PARKER: No.
ROGER PENG: Oh, actually, I
haven't turned off my Wi-Fi.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Reboot your router?
Yeah.
[LAUGHS] Almost always
my internet is an issue.
ROGER PENG: Verify microphone?
I think the people
in the back that seem
to know what they're doing.
Verify recording?
We are recording.
All right.
Hard wired.
I'm not recording today.
Files being written?
I'm not doing that.
HILARY PARKER: We did once
do a whole podcast episode
where we did not record.
That's right.
Yeah, so once that
happened, like never again.
Guess how that made
it onto the checklist?
Yeah.
[LAUGHS] We did a
blameless postmortem.
Levels seems to be OK?
Yeah.
All right.
And it is close to 5 o'clock.
Yeah.
So--
Verify that my
cat's been feed.
--you feed your cat?
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, she does-- from 4 to 5,
she starts to interrupt things.
That was more of an issue
when you were in Melbourne.
Yeah.
Yeah, so all right, so I
think we're go for launch?
Yeah, we're launched.
So welcome to the Not
So Standard Deviations
episode 100.
[APPLAUSE]
I'm Roger Peng from the Johns
Hopkins Bloomberg School
of Public Health.
And I'm here with Hilary
Parker of Stitch Fix.
So this episode is our
first ever live episode.
It's, I guess, ironically not
going to be about R or RStudio.
Yeah.
It's possible we showed
up at the wrong conference.
But I hope you'll enjoy it.
I think it'll be fun.
Yeah, yeah.
We also did some
prep, unusually.
Usually we kind of show up
and call each other and say,
I was thinking about
talking about this.
And so this time we actually
have some materials.
Yes.
Yeah.
All right, so
there are probably
a few people in the audience
who haven't heard of
or heard our podcast,
so we thought
we'd just talk a
little bit about kind
of why we're here, what we're
doing, why we're doing this.
And so I guess this
started in 2015,
right after the rOpenSci
Unconference here
in San Francisco, where Hilary
and I kind of caught up.
And I sent her an email.
I said, hey--
I think the subject
of the email was
I want to broadcast your
opinions to the world.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Because Hilary
has a few opinions.
And I thought there's nothing
the internet likes more
than a strongly
opinionated person.
So I sent her an
email, said, hey, I
think we could do a
data science podcast.
I don't think there's
exactly what I'm
thinking about out there already
in terms of other data science
podcasts.
And so do you want to do it?
And so she got back to me.
She said yes.
And I sent her a wall
of text email saying,
here's what I
think we should do.
And then there was no response.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
But then--
--a week later,
I apologized a lot.
Yes.
And it was true that my
boss quit that week, so there
was some reason, but, yeah, it
was mostly the wall of text.
Said yes and then
we just went for it.
Yeah, for five years.
Or almost five years, I
should say, so 99 episodes.
And so here we are.
So we've been talking
about a lot of things
over the past five years.
And one of the things
that we realized
as we were preparing
for this keynote
is that we have a record
of everything we've said.
Yeah.
Yeah, so I wanted to make sure
there there's a visual impact
here.
But I actually printed out the
transcripts of every episode
and leafed through them.
Because it's kind of rare
that you have the ability
to see what you were
thinking over a period
of time like this,
aside from kind
of, like, a personal journal.
Which I have joked that
the podcast is a little bit
of a personal journal.
But yeah, so we wanted
to look back and see
what themes were coming up.
And we never set
out with an agenda
for this, although I kind
of thought you did at first.
But we just wanted to chat.
And then what was surprising
was that we actually got
some places during these chats.
And so part of the reason
I wanted to look back
through these
transcripts was to see
how thoughts evolved over time.
So just before we move
on to the next thing,
I just wanted to
mention, as we were kind
of leading up to this keynote--
they asked us to do
this a while back
and we saw kind of
who else was going up.
So for example, JJ's keynote
yesterday, it was amazing.
And a lot-- maybe
coincidentally or not,
touched on a lot of themes
that we had been discussing
in terms of open source.
Yeah.
And for those of
you who are wondering,
we're not going to
talk about that here.
Yeah, we're not going to
talk about open source at all.
So even though our episodes
have been leading up to that--
and again, we may have had
some information there that
emboldened those
conversations, but--
Look out for episode 101.
Yeah, episode 101 we'll
get back on track with that.
Yeah, we wanted
to touch on those.
The keynotes have
been awesome so far.
And especially, I mean,
JJ's was really good.
And we were joking about
the fact that, didn't
realize what a nerd he was.
[LAUGHTER]
Or what, like, a
policy nerd he was.
[LAUGHS]
I told him it
warmed by heart when
he brought up the case history
of the Delaware Supreme Court.
Nothing more riveting than--
[LAUGHTER]
Nothing more riveting than a
little bit of corporate case
law, you know?
[LAUGHS] Exactly.
And it was just so
lucky that someone
who had so much interest
in public policy,
but then became a
highly productive coder
for many years, and then circled
back and brought them together.
It's unusual.
And then, yeah,
the second keynote
with all that data visualization
really spoke to me.
Because at Stitch Fix, I
work a lot with outfit data.
There's a lot of imagery
in fashion, right?
And so I was really inspired
by that about different ways
to visualize the data.
And actually, JJ also
was talking about this--
the book was called
Shop Class as Soulcraft
and this idea of
touching the data
and making the data yourself.
And looking through
this transcript,
actually, you had
mentioned Scott Zeger
talking about writing
the data down by hand.
And so I thought
that was awesome.
That actually comes
from John Tukey,
who talks about scratching
the numbers down.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Oh, there you go.
I have to say, when we saw
that the two people from Google
were going to talk
at keynote, we
didn't know what
it was going to be,
but I was like, oh, that one's
going to be good, actually.
[LAUGHS] They're going to--
--be very polished,
very prepared.
We're like, let's
do the opposite.
Yeah, right?
Let's run in the opposite
direction of whatever they do.
Yeah, that was where the idea
of the live episode came from.
Yeah.
And then Jenny's
talk was great, too.
She always has that amazing--
Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
She has an incredible
ability to just see
that higher level of stuff after
having been in the trenches
for so long.
Exactly, yeah.
Like, going into the detail and
understanding the nitty gritty,
but then being able to zoom out
and create the paradigm for it.
It's not easy, so good work.
[LAUGHS]
Don't get too
comfortable, though.
No, but I feel like this
conference has been awesome.
And we have, like, we have
fodder for many episodes
following up on this.
And such a great vibe.
This is your first--
It's my first rstudio::conf.
That's right, yeah.
So we went through--
so one of the ideas that
we had for this keynote
was to kind of go through
our thought process
for the last five years,
which was made a lot of user
by looking at the transcripts,
listening to the audio,
hearing what we've
been talking about.
And as we did that
in preparation,
we noticed a number of kind
of interesting moments,
of course, and kind
of recurring theme.
One of the interesting
moments that we had,
actually really
early on the podcast,
was our first and only really
kind of use of profanity.
[LAUGHS]
And maybe I just want to
ask, maybe do a quick poll--
who thinks it was me and
who thinks it was Hilary?
Who thinks it was Hilary?
[APPLAUSE]
Wow.
Who thinks it was me?
[APPLAUSE]
About 50-50.
Let me play you this clip.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNY BRYAN (RECORDING): When
people use spread-shit sheets,
they're trying to avoid
syntax bull [MUTED]
and data structure bull [MUTED].
Because we have a lot of that
in any scripting language
where you have to a fair
amount of syntax and get fairly
facile with data structures.
Thank you, Jenny Bryan.
[LAUGHTER]
That was a really
popular episode.
It was.
Those are, like, super early
days when Jenny was defending
spreadsheets, essentially.
Or like, talking about having
empathy with spreadsheets.
Explaining the
attraction of spreadsheets.
Yeah.
Another theme-- one of the
most controversial things I
think we've ever discussed on
the podcast involves this topic
here.
HILARY PARKER
(RECORDING): And I want
to point out that you got
an oatmeal raisin cookie.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
What is the problem?
You're, like, the 10th person
whose called me out on this.
HILARY PARKER (RECORDING):
They're terrible.
Why does anyone choose those?
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
They're delicious.
ROGER PENG
(RECORDING): All right.
[INAUDIBLE]
OK.
I'm just going to have
to enjoy them in private.
HILARY PARKER (RECORDING):
Yeah, as you should.
[LAUGHTER]
That's like a
dagger in the heart.
"As you should, yeah."
Oatmeal cookies to this day
get us a lot of feedback.
Yeah.
Terrible.
And apparently there's
huge plate of them
outside ready for me to eat,
since no one else wants them.
I also love-- that episode,
we literally recorded in a Jimmy
John's.
That's right.
I was in town for
my brother's wedding.
And we met in the middle between
DC-- my brother lives in DC
and we met in the middle
between DC and Baltimore
at a Jimmy John's
and recorded it.
And you ordered an
oatmeal raisin cookie.
That's right, yeah, hence
the interesting soundtrack
in the back there.
Yeah.
[LAUGHS]
One recurring theme
that has played out
over multiple episodes is Hilary
trying to get me to do stuff.
Yeah.
And so one of those things
is getting Netflix, apparently.
So here's--
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
My only problem
actually is that I
don't have Netflix.
HILARY PARKER
(RECORDING): Oh, come on,
you can shell out for, like--
it's, like, $8 a month, Roger.
That's episode 3.
Episode 3.
Episode 28.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
Oh, the other piece of news
that's really important is
that I finally got Netflix.
And 28 is, like,
a year later, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, because we do it
once every two months, so
took you a while--
Two weeks, yeah.
Yeah, once every two weeks.
Episode 36.
HILARY PARKER (RECORDING):
So if you have access to HBO,
highly recommend.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING): Oh, HBO.
You're like, I have to
buy another service.
HILARY PARKER (RECORDING):
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
I bought Netflix for you.
HILARY PARKER (RECORDING):
[LAUGHS] Sorry.
Yeah, this one's
an HBO exclusive.
Yeah.
ROGER PENG
(RECORDING): All right.
HILARY PARKER (RECORDING):
It's $14.99 a month.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
I'll just eat the cost.
So we went from $8 to $14.99.
I just kind of wonder what
I'm going to have to pay next.
And then episode 70.
HILARY PARKER (RECORDING):
They're on Netflix?
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
I would assume so.
Who knows what's on
Netflix these days?
[LAUGHS] So apparently, I
wasn't really watching it.
Yeah, OK, so this is--
I have some follow
up, which is that--
so I have some notes here.
Episode 6, you
say, I love movies.
OK.
Episode 13, you
say, I'm a film nerd.
And then many times, you talked
about this script book thing,
which was predicting whether
a movie would be successful
based on it's script, like
algorithms for doing that.
And then Walt Hickey
came on and you'd, like,
read his blog posts about
books versus movies.
And you know about Steven
Spielberg table reads.
I feel like I want the
visual of handing you--
like here's all the time
you've talked about movies.
But do you not watch movies?
Like, how does this work?
Like, are you just interested
in movies intellectually
and never watch them?
I infer their content.
No, but, like, I really
want to answer here.
Like, do you watch Netflix?
This isn't an act.
This is--
Yeah, no.
[LAUGHS]
You know, things have slowed
down in terms of my movie
watching activity.
But you enjoy the craft?
I do.
Yeah, so OK--
[LAUGHS] that's just weird.
I just want you to know that.
So noted.
Yeah.
Anyway, the transcripts really
brought that home for me,
because I had never
put those together.
And I didn't realize
you said early on
that you were a film nerd.
You were like, I
love living in LA--
or you lived in
LA in grad school.
Anyway, so those are
kind of like our fun
going back and recurring themes.
But what we really
wanted to talk about
was this kind of overarching
thing actually Hadley
kind of alluded to, which is
the idea of the role of design
in data science.
And this was something
we chewed on for so long,
of essentially, how do
you do data analysis.
And one thing that really
struck me looking at it
was that literally in episode
1, we talked about it a lot.
And actually, for a
long time, I thought
that this was why you
wanted to do the podcast,
was to solve this problem.
I had no agenda.
And it is surprising to look
at that first transcript
to see how many
seeds were planted.
Exactly.
Like, we actually talked about--
we hit words and themes that
were kind of where we got to,
but I don't think we
had a way of recognizing
that those were going to
be important at the time.
So we have three
clips from episode 1.
Just to be clear, we
started this episode
talking about our cat ladies.
Yeah, that's right.
So agenda was
not super strong.
Yeah, and our cat lady--
this is a little dated at this
point, but it was this
hashtag for seeing your cat
on your keyboard while
you're writing R,
which happens to
me all the time.
Anyway.
Yeah, so anyway, this
is from the first episode.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING): We have
this habit of telling people--
giving people a bunch
of choices, right?
Like, you could do
this, you can do
that, you could
so regression, you
could do smoother, whatever.
Just pick.
There's, like, five different
models that you could--
[LAUGHS] or strategies
that you could implement.
But we often don't
like tell people
how to you choose between
those types of things.
It's almost like we
explicitly don't do it.
The recording quality
in the early days was--
I know.
You can really tell
from these clips
the variance in my recording
quality, personally.
But let just put these down.
[LAUGHS] Thump.
But yeah, so to set that
clip up a little bit more,
you'd had an experience teaching
a stat class, where at the end,
someone essentially said to
you, like, as a statistician,
I think you did a good job
of telling me things to do
and you told me definitely
things not to do.
But now how do I
know what to do?
Right.
Like, thanks for teaching
me all this stuff.
I still don't know anything.
Yeah, I still know
nothing and I still know--
you sit me down
with a data set, I
don't know like how to proceed.
Right, yeah.
And this person got
an A in the class,
so this is by far and away.
And my favorite
part about that, too,
is that you kind of set it up
as you were like, good point.
And it was the second
to last lecture.
So you'd go to your
office and sit down
and try to write it out.
Like, OK, here's what to do.
Here's what data
analysis is in one lecture.
Yeah, like here's how to
craft the perfect analysis.
Yeah, it didn't work.
It didn't work.
I think I came away with
a few bullet points.
I had a lot more thinking
to do, apparently.
That was about, I
guess, 10 years ago now.
Wow, yeah.
OK, so the second clip is--
RECORDING: So I
was thinking when
you were saying that is that
part of a successful data
analysis is convincing
someone of something.
And that is inherently
like a one-on-one process.
Yeah, so we touched
on this, like,
what does success look like?
Right.
Yeah, like, that was kind of
what this woman was getting at.
It's like, OK, I
have to do something,
I have to accomplish something.
What is that thing?
And how do I decide
how to do it?
Right.
Yeah.
And we don't touch the
how to decide at all,
but at least we started
to circle around what
does it look like to
do this thing that we
talk about that, that this
whole conference is about.
And recognizing that human
beings are involved in it.
Yeah, and humans
are involved, yeah.
And that's to lead
into the 3rd clip.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING): I think
it's this human element that
is missing, I think, from a lot
of talk about data analysis.
HILARY PARKER
(RECORDING): It's hard.
And actually that gets
into the next topic
of kind of who's building
successful tools.
And I think it has a lot to
do with people who genuinely
have empathy with the user.
Yeah, so that was empathy.
I feel like it was a little--
but yeah, these
were, again, kind
of things we threw out
and didn't think about
for a long time, but ended up
being central themes to what we
were talking about later.
Yeah.
That's episode 1.
Yeah, episode 1.
Covered that.
Moving on.
So throughout, so we
kind have this timeline
of what this looks like
evolving over time.
And one of the things--
and again, this was,
like, 4 and 1/2 years ago.
I was still working at Etsy.
And Etsy had this kind
of amazing DevOps team.
And so for those of
you who don't know,
DevOps stands for a
developer operator.
And it's this field where--
essentially it was like kind
of taking IT to the next level.
So it was the same--
the people who
run the website,
the people who keep
the servers on for the website,
the people who do everything
to kind of keep this
shopping website up,
they should also be the
people developing the tools
to keep the website up.
And so it's, like,
developer operator.
And at Google, they kind
of have a different word
for it, site
reliability engineer,
but it's the same thing.
And I was really inspired
by that work and kind
of how they approach problems.
One of the central
tenants was this idea
of a blameless postmortem, where
if you ran into a problem--
like, let's say
your system failed
and the website went down--
there is a human
tendency to blame
the person who wrote the
code that failed or whatever.
But Etsy focused
a lot on instead
doing this thing called a
blameless postmortem, where
you talk about--
you frame the problem
as though the system
failed the operator, rather
than the operator failing
within a good system.
And then that opens
up the conversation
to talk about iterating
on the systems.
And saying, OK, this person
went to work this day,
said they wanted
to do a good job.
They did not say they wanted
to take down the website.
But then the system allowed
them to take down the website.
And so based on
this kind of idea
of how do we know
what to do, there
were sort of these two
threads that started it.
One was how do we
decide how to build
the artifact--
like the dashboard
or the email or the
report or whatever.
And then there was
this kind of, like,
how do you build a narrative.
And so I think like the theme
of the early part of the podcast
really for the first year
was focused on that artifact
question of how do you build a
system that doesn't fail you?
How do you decide
what to do in order
to make an analysis
happen that works for you?
And I was really energized by
connecting these two things
and being like,
well, the way we can
talk about it as a community
is building systems
that help you avoid errors.
And articulating what those
errors are, putting cost
with those errors, and then
making design decisions
for your system around that.
Yeah.
A lot of the struggle that
we had was in terms of kind
of identifying the
constraints and identifying
kind of the framing
of this problem
and otherwise, it's so open.
Yeah, and if you don't
define this problem that way
from kind of more
first principles,
you end up in these like
nasty language wars.
Or you get people who are
just saying like, you should
use this, you should use knitr.
And you don't talk about why.
And it's like, OK, when is
it appropriate to use knitr?
If you want to avoid
these types of errors,
you don't want to
update your data,
but have your report be stale.
That's a huge one.
And so being able to talk about
the system that way, I think,
was an important part of this
kind of thread of thought.
And so again, we kind
of separated out that.
And I personally
focus on that a lot.
I mean, we both did, but I think
that was in my head because
of Etsy so much.
And then by doing that,
I kind of purposely
like siphoned off the
narrative building.
And I was like, I don't
want to talk about that.
That seems really hard.
But then I feel like you
ran with that a little bit.
Well, first--
First, you moved
to San Francisco.
First-- yeah, so I quit Etsy
and I moved to San Francisco.
And just this kind of
aside, we do this--
in old days, we did
this free advertising.
And so one thing that
happened in episode 22
was that I talked about a
meditation class I was taking.
So hit the clip.
HILARY PARKER (RECORDING):
This is my very San Francisco
advertising, where I'm
taking a meditation class,
but I'm really enjoying it.
[LAUGHS] And so it's
this program called
mindfulness-based
stress reduction.
And it's like a whole thing.
There's a Wikipedia.
It's a whole thing.
That's the whole thing, yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
And so, again, that's just kind
of like a thing that popped up
didn't seem related at all,
but ended up folding in later.
So just kind of
planting that seed now.
So anyway, like I was
saying, we kind of
siphoned off the
system design, which
I think is a big part of
this conference and other R
conferences of how
do you do that.
How do you do that in a
way that is user friendly?
What types of tools
enable you to do that?
But then that left
this huge, like,
how do you convince someone
of something, essentially.
And so you started to
think about that a lot.
And you had a really interesting
episode where you were, like,
preparing for a talk, right?
I had to give a lecture.
I got promoted.
All the full professors
that get promoted at Hopkins
give a lecture.
And I had to give a talk.
And I wanted to kind of--
I just want to play
some music in the talk.
And so I had to kind of figure
out some theoretical framework
for me being able to put
audio clips into the lecture.
So I guess that's--
I mean, it's a
reasonable motivation.
That's right.
And another professor had,
like, his entire lecture--
he was a biostatistics
professor.
And his entire
lecture was, like,
talking about a Wagner opera.
Right.
[INAUDIBLE]
Anyway.
No stats.
Anyway, so you had to like--
So I started thinking about,
I've had long history of music.
I played the violin for
know how however old I am,
30-some years or-- that's
not how old I am, but--
[LAUGHTER]
That's how long
I've been playing.
And I've studied music theory.
I've done a lot of
that kind of work.
And I just started thinking
that there kind of were
some connections between what
we do as data analysts and kind
of how we think about music.
And this is just a little
bit of what we talked about
in that episode.
Oops.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING): The
more I thought about it,
the more I felt like there
were kind of connections
between what we do in data
analysis-- or not what we do,
what we need in data analysis
and kind of music theory,
right?
And so the basic idea is that--
music is considered to be a
very kind of subjective area,
in terms of like what
you think is good
and what you think
is not good, right?
But that said, most of us have
a sense of what sounds good
and what doesn't sound good.
Right.
I think I talked a lot about
there is a theory of harmony,
there is a theory of
melody, in terms of how
to construct certain things.
And those rules don't
produce the best music,
but they do allow us to describe
and to kind of summarize
what it is that people
seem to like about music.
And it's not an absolute theory.
It's a very kind
of based in culture
and based in people's
kind of collective ideas,
but there is a theoretical
structure there.
And there's some
science to it.
I mean, there's literally
wave properties.
There is a little
physics involved, yeah.
Yeah, and then there's
kind of like a psychology
or something--
like wanting to hear chords
resolved, for example.
I'm not totally sure what--
I don't know.
I mean, I'm like, continue
this thought please.
I don't know much about--
[LAUGHS]
So I got very deep
in the weeds of this,
reading Arnold
Schoenberg's Harmonielehre.
And the way he
summarizes it, I think,
the best in the sense
that the theory doesn't
say what's right.
The theory says
what's commonly done.
And so the idea that
the five chord resolves
to the one chord, that's
not because it's right,
it's just because
that seems to be
what everyone does
and it seems to be
kind of not too bad of an idea.
Yeah.
But if you don't resolve the
five chord to the one chord,
it's not, like, a
theoretical violation.
I'm just laughing because--
Uh-oh.
[LAUGHS] Well, I'm just
thinking about that second
lecture or the second keynote,
where he got like really
defensive about pie charts.
And I think that's exactly--
it's what people are doing.
You can't argue with that.
It is commonly done.
Yeah, and it
seems to work for--
I'm with him.
Like, for certain things.
This is what happens
at our podcast.
We get sidetracked--
We get sidetracked.
[LAUGHS]
And then, like, two
hours later, we end.
Yeah.
OK, anyway.
[LAUGHS]
I'm just trying to
illustrate that you were right.
Oh, OK.
Yeah.
So, OK, during this
episode, too, I sort of
bring up where my
mind had been going.
So at this point, I'd
moved to Stitch Fix.
And I had some
really amazing people
I worked with in the product org
who allowed me to participate
more in product design.
One of the things was
doing at design sprint,
which is kind of a whole thing.
But essentially, I
could see how design
was working more closely.
And so hit the clip.
Yeah.
HILARY PARKER
(RECORDING): It's funny,
because I was concurrently
thinking about this, too,
in terms of designers,
who I think actually
have a very similar--
like, their place
is an organization
is very similar to a data.
Like, they're usually kind
of a cross-functional team,
horizontally integrated.
And then you also have--
it's very
problem-solving focused.
It's very focused on--
it's similar to like
the consulting model.
But I think that they're
more willing to talk
about that connection.
Like, design is about the
user and designing for a team.
I feel like when you look
at design conferences,
it's a lot more focused on that.
But then also their
products are on display.
So I think that sharing
what people are doing
is easier, because you literally
see design elements on websites
when you go to them.
Yeah, so I was thinking
about design at the same time
you were thinking
about music theory.
Yeah, I think
we thought we were
talking about different things.
Yeah, exactly.
Right?
Yeah, like two different ways
of approaching this problem.
So kind of in the middle
here, I brought it
up getting into meditation more.
And then I essentially,
in the middle of all this,
I'm kind of reading
about design.
And one thing you see when you
start to look into design more
is they talk so
much about empathy--
empathy for the users.
And that's something that
is just an accepted fact
about working in that field.
And so at the same time I'm
getting more into meditation,
I'm reading more
kind of connections
between neuroscience
and meditation.
And so I read this really
dense Atlantic article
where it was a discussion
between a neuroscientist
and a Buddhist monk.
And they're talking kind
of about experiences.
And so, why don't you--
Just be clear, this episode,
I read the transcript again.
I'm still not sure
I understand what--
What I was trying to say.
--we were talking about.
Yeah.
HILARY PARKER
(RECORDING): Data analysis
to influence decision making
has to span both the world where
third person perspective
and kind of this,
like, scientific truth world is
and then also that first person
eliciting belief in another
human, when you can't really
observe what will make that
person start to believe
your results or trust it.
So anyway, I thought
it added clar--
to me, it added some clarity of
the complexity of what we do.
Yeah, so to set that up,
the idea was essentially that
neuroscientists, they
can study-- in this case,
they're talking about studying
people who are meditating.
And you can't exactly
empirically observe,
someone's in a meditative state.
You can measure their
brainwaves and stuff,
but ultimately, you have to
rely on the person telling you
that they're in
that state, so you
can correlate the brainwaves
with them having that state.
And so to me, it
was kind of similar,
where in order for an
analysis to be successful,
someone has to be, like,
I get it now, you know?
They have to tell you it's--
Yeah, they have to tell
you that they get it.
And you can't observe it.
I mean, you can obviously see
their face change or whatever,
but they're having a
first-person experience.
And so I was just
teasing apart like,
oh, yeah, you have to
use scientific methods
and be in this world of science.
But then also you have
to tap into this kind
of deeply empathetic thing of
seeing where their mind is.
And that's hard.
[LAUGHS]
I think I get it now.
Yeah, yeah, good.
Did we have other clips
from this episode?
I don't think so.
No.
Yeah.
Another thing --
I think we might have
a clip for this one.
I was talking about how
blameless postmortems--
around the same
time, too, I started
to see how blameless
postmortems were--
well, why don't you
just play the clip?
HILARY PARKER (RECORDING):
I think the biggest thing
I realized sort of almost right
after was that in some ways
the sort of blameless postmortem
stuff is a design process.
And it's a way of almost making
a system to force everyone
to be empathetic.
[LAUGHS] Yeah, because the
point of blameless postmortem
is essentially to say,
here, listen to the problem.
Don't blame the user.
Try to put yourself
in their shoes.
They essentially force you.
Like, you can't
use you statements.
There's a lot of
rules of engagement.
And so it all kind of
started coming together.
We're on the path.
We're on the path, yeah.
And the path
ends at episode 63.
Or at least the first
milestone, which
was the start-- some of
you, if you were listeners,
will remember the
seven part book club
that we had for Nigel
Cross's Design Thinking.
Which some liked and some
thought was too long.
[LAUGHTER]
Oh.
I don't want to hear that.
But we'll talk
about feedback later.
Yeah.
Yeah, so I'll
play the clip here.
Just so you know the
name of the clip.
Oh, and this clip
also really exemplifies
the podcast for people
who don't listen,
where it takes us a little
while to get to the point.
Yes, in case you haven't
already figured that out.
Yeah.
The name of this file
is all caps texting.
All right.
Oops, that's not
what I was meant to do.
Here we go.
ROGER PENG
(RECORDING): And all I
know is I got these
messages that are,
like, I guess you took a picture
of the Kindle with your phone
and then texted me the picture?
Is that right?
HILARY PARKER (RECORDING):
[LAUGHS] That is correct.
ROGER PENG
(RECORDING): And so I'm
like reading your
photo of a Kindle.
[LAUGHTER]
HILARY PARKER
(RECORDING): Well, can you
take a screenshot of a Kindle?
I feel like--
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
I've never owned one,
so I'm not sure.
HILARY PARKER
(RECORDING): Oh, you're
just, like, tablet all the way.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
Definitely.
So then I'm reading
these screens--
they're not screenshots.
They're photos of a screen.
HILARY PARKER (RECORDING):
Well, no, OK, photos
of an eInk screen.
Yeah.
I do have a moment
of pain when I see
a photo of a computer screen.
ROGER PENG
(RECORDING): And then I
think what ensued was
a series of like all
caps exchanges between you and
me that are like, oh, my god,
I can't believe-- this
is exactly what we're
talking about.
HILARY PARKER
(RECORDING): Exactly.
Yeah, no, it was like,
oh, this articulates
what we've been
trying to say in,
like, a few sentences
versus you've
written a series
of long blog posts.
I mean, I think that
they're still valuable.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
But not good concise.
Yeah, so I feel this
is was a moment where
we were talking about these--
I guess the book's called
Designerly Ways of Knowing?
Yeah.
And we were kind
of reading it.
And she's sending me
photos of the book.
And I'm reading the
book along with her.
And I'm like, send
me the next page.
Yeah.
And it was like--
so this was a book essentially
about the theory of--
academic theory around
design and design work.
And it was just, like, to
us, it was this huge aha
moment of like, oh, it's all
starting to really make sense.
And what was making sense is
that the way the designers
work and the way that
they structure the work,
the way they talk about
it, you could essentially
swap in the word data analysis
and it was the same thing.
In so many ways, yeah.
Yeah, in so many ways.
Like, the way that designers
talk about getting briefs,
where it's like, oh,
you get a design brief
and then you don't just--
as a designer, you don't just
do what the person asked you,
because that will
be like a subpar--
the person doesn't
know what they want.
They have figured out
some way to articulate it,
but your job as a designer
is to zoom out and identify
what they actually
need and then make
the best solution about that.
But they're going to communicate
what they need via what
they think the solution is.
And that's the same--
I mean, I think about that all
the time with, like, someone
asks you for a number.
They're like, can you
get me this number?
And then as a data
analyst, you have
to zoom out and be like,
no, OK, what problem are you
trying to solve?
Why don't you catch me
up on what you're doing
and maybe I'm
going to solve this
in a totally different way?
Some of my
collaborators, I think,
would want me to just
give them the number.
I know, yeah.
That's OK, though.
They don't stay
collaborators for long.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
That sounded way darker
than I meant it to.
[LAUGHTER]
I just stop working with them.
It's not like-- yeah.
You don't want that.
So that's kind of the
end of our audio clips.
But essentially, we got to
this place where it's like, OK,
data analysis is a type
of essentially either
an independent thing or a
type of design thinking,
where it's like, the answer
to this student's question
is essentially adopt this
whole other way of approaching
the world that's totally
different than science.
And we haven't totally--
as a field, we haven't totally
addressed that difference.
I kind of wonder about what
I would have told that student
now, more than 10 years later.
And the way I kind
of think about it
is that when you go outside,
you don't see a data
analysis walking around, right?
It doesn't naturally
occur like a tree or--
what else naturally occurs--
a rock.
[LAUGHTER]
I only know about trees.
So if it doesn't
naturally occur,
it has to be built
by someone or it
has to be designed by someone
and it has to be built.
And so why shouldn't we
use the same ideas there
for a data analysis as you
might for a chair or a bridge
or whatever.
That's a good point.
Yeah, I mean, same
with the music, too,
where obviously noises exist,
but crafting the noises
in a way that's pleasing is, in
many ways, even though it's R,
it's also design.
Yeah.
And yeah, no, it's a
good way of putting it.
Like, essentially you're
constructing something.
And then I also think
what's interesting is
that whether you're building
a production machine learning
pipeline or you're
building an analysis,
the tools are different, the
types of testing you'll do
is different, kind of the
technical requirements
are different, but
ultimately, you're
doing the same thing,
which is you're
creating something that's going
to do something for someone.
[LAUGHS] Like, either it's going
to be a recommender system that
creates recommendations
for a website
or it's this analysis
that some sort of person
is going to consume and make
a decision based on that.
Might just be a PDF document.
Yeah, it could be--
I mean, literally even
an email with one number
in it is still--
you have to decide like,
OK, this problem can
be sufficiently
addressed with an email
and that person doesn't
need much context.
And therefore, if I just
send them the email,
that will be enough to
convince them to do something.
Yeah.
And so that put us on a really
interesting path of like,
OK, so if we think that data
science is a type of design,
then how do designers work?
If you look at architects,
how are they trained?
If you look at other
designers, how do they
work in companies, et cetera?
And so one of the things in this
Design Thinking book by Nigel
Cross is talking a
lot about, you just
have to do it over and over.
And you're going to get
better every time you do it.
You're going to go through
different thought processes.
But you have to literally
exercise the part of your brain
that does this
constructive thinking,
rather than like the
deductive thinking of science.
OK, so in data
science, we kind of
don't do that apprenticeship
model so much.
I mean, I think we
wish we didn't have to I
think is what it comes down to.
Yeah, like, we wish we
could just teach the stuff
and be done with it.
Because it's a lot of work
to go through someone's work
and tell them if
it's working or not.
But ultimately, if
we kind of accept
that this is a type of
design and construction,
then you need to be
able to practice it.
So we did some cool
stuff with that where--
kind of very different than
the types of challenges
you'd do with Kaggle and
stuff, where they're like,
here's a data set.
Analyze it.
Instead it was
like, OK, let's say
you had to build your
system end-to-end.
You needed to answer
some question.
We did commute times.
[LAUGHS]
Right.
We talked about--
well, your commute.
Yeah, my commute.
So it was, in San
Francisco, I want
to know exactly how many
minutes and the variance
in those minutes for
different commute methods
so I can know the
last possible minute
that I can leave my apartment
to make it to a meeting.
And so it's like, OK,
how would you solve that?
How would you get the data
to solve that problem?
How would you store it?
How would you access it?
How would you analyze it?
How would you display it?
And then how
would you model it?
What are the fixed effects?
What are the random effects?
Exactly.
You know, it's
amazing how just
a simple kind of
formulation of a problem
can bring in every single
aspect of design, of analysis,
presentation, communication.
Yeah, exactly.
Like, you're doing
the whole thing.
And what I like
about it, too, is
that the things
like how you store
the data is sort of on the same
par as what models you choose.
All of those things are equal.
You have to end up spending
time on all of it, instead of--
I feel like as a field--
and what I like
about this conference
is that, less so
here, but as a field
we focus so much
just on the methods.
And that really bothers me, in
case that hasn't been clear.
And actually, I was talking
with someone last night
about that, where I'm like,
you know in some ways--
the way that normal data science
conference are structured,
it's like everyone wants
to talk about the best
method, the latest thing.
And literally, in
that system, you're
motivated to have bad
data, because it gives you
more opportunity to
do fancier models.
And so any system
where it's like, OK,
this person could work
on worse and worse data
and be equally
happy, because they
get to do all these
fancy things they learned
at this conference, is like,
that's not solving the problem.
That's choosing not
to solve the problem.
So by focusing on the whole
thing, it's like, no, OK,
can you hone in on exactly what
data you need, rather than just
making do with what has
fallen into your lap one
way or another?
I think one of the hardest
things to do in general,
but also in data sciences
is to kind of pull back
from trying to maximize
in a single dimension.
Yeah.
And to me, the
way I interpreted--
and even JJ's talk is like,
the way that corporations are
structured is they
maximize on one dimension.
Yeah.
And I think it's hard--
that can end up with some
good and then some bad.
I think in data
science, it's very
tempting to kind of go
for the optimal approach,
go for the optimal method,
go for the best prediction.
But there are other elements,
there's other stakeholders,
there's other
trade-offs to be made.
I really like that,
because in the second talk,
she just touched it
briefly at the end
that it was like,
what are UX problems
and what are designer problems?
And then the one that was
like, this is actually a design
problem was the loss function.
Like, it seems like it's
just a data science problem,
but that's actually
the core user
experience is what
loss function you use
and what system are
you actually building.
And what I like about
that is that it's
the same with the
corporation thing.
It's like, what was the loss
function before versus--
like, change the KPIs basically.
KPI, key performance indicator.
I don't deal with KPIs.
What?
Yeah, you don't
deal with KPIs.
Not yet, at least.
Yeah, like the way I've been
talking about that at Stitch
Fix is like, yeah, rather than
just optimizing for sales,
how can we construct
new KPIs that might lead
to different user experiences?
Part of me, I feel like
it'd be great if we could move
to a place where instead of
saying this is the best thing,
we could say, I really
appreciate this set
of trade-offs.
Yeah, yeah.
I like that.
I don't know.
But it doesn't quite--
doesn't sound as nice, I guess.
I don't know.
I think it sounds--
OK.
Anyway.
I know I have one
person with me here.
[LAUGHTER]
One other thing that-- kind
of the end of this timeline,
this has just been briefly.
But essentially by
getting to this place,
now it opens up a whole other
set of fields to look into,
which is everything around
creativity, so like all of--
the book that we're
mentioning here
is called The Creative Curve.
And we had a one episode
book club on that.
We learned our lesson.
Yeah.
[LAUGHS] I was actually about to
suggest that we should do more.
I was like, let's
retroactively go back
and do, like, three
episodes on that one.
Anyway.
But the idea with that was that
it was this guy, Allen Gannett,
who essentially empirically
studied creative people
and how they operate.
And I thought it was awesome.
I mean, I really liked it.
It really made me feel like,
oh, I can apply these principles
to my data science work.
And the principles were--
let's make sure--
[LAUGHS] I don't think
I did ever write that down.
Consumption.
Yeah, so there
was consumption.
So creative people
will frequent--
well, this is why I'm
confused with you.
So people who are
engaged in movie making,
they watch movies,
like, 20% of the time.
You're not like that
for whatever reason.
That's like a difference story.
[LAUGHS] But just again,
from like empirically
looking at people who are
in these creative fields,
consuming other people's
work is a big part of it.
And you digest it.
You think about it.
And you iterate on it.
And I think that aspect--
I mean, if you want to write,
you read a lot of books.
If you want to write music,
you listen a lot of music.
One of the aspects that's
typical about data analysis,
it's not always easy to
read a lot of data analysis,
because they're not out there.
Yeah, especially in
the corporate world,
like data science specifically.
If you have a big
team, you can read
what other people are doing,
but otherwise, basically only
at conferences.
Or David Robinson's
livestream.
Yeah.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
It's hard to consume
a lot of data analysis,
I think is what
it comes down to.
I think that's a
key step to becoming
an expert in something.
Yeah, that was a
great point, yeah.
Iteration.
Iteration, yeah so--
is their imitation, too?
Iteration.
Yeah, so iteration is this
idea that you just keep going.
You keep trying things.
You do it over and over.
And again, that kind of
is touched in the design
literature, too,
where it's just like,
you've gotta keep
doing things and ideas
are going to evolve over time.
And part of why we wanted
to go through those clips
and put up this timeline is
that even the creativity that we
got from this podcast, that
I totally wasn't expecting--
like, it took us four years.
Like, this timeline
is over four years.
Yeah, timeline's not to scale.
Yeah, it's definitely
not to scale.
And so it's like,
the number of ways
that we attack this problem
and thought about it was a lot.
And it never felt like
it was work, necessarily.
It was just, like,
iterating and going on.
And then there's
the community.
Yeah, so the community one.
Another one is
creative communities.
And so you look at artists
and Andy Warhol, right,
had the factory, I
think, where it was just
a bunch of artists in a loft
painting, giving feedback,
everything.
And so with that,
essentially it's
like surrounding yourself
with other creative people
helps help you be creative.
And so that's kind of like,
I feel like my sitcom happy
ending here.
It's, like, coming to
conferences like this,
they're fun, they're energizing.
And I do think they kind of
embody this creative community,
especially because
so many people are
isolated as data scientists.
Like, not every company
has 100 data scientists.
Most companies don't.
And so being able to get
together and bounce ideas
off and see what other
people are doing--
I guess what I'm trying to
say is that is the work.
It's not like this
isn't productive,
if that makes sense.
If there was one agenda
item for starting the podcast,
I think part of it was
to produce that community
for people who may be sitting
in a department somewhere
or in a company
somewhere by themselves.
They're forced to be
the lone data analyst.
And they don't have
anyone to talk to
or they don't have the
ability to kind of hear
what other people are
working on and how they're
approaching things like that.
Yeah, and that's actually--
that's some of the most
meaningful feedback I hear is
when people are like, oh, yeah,
I'm like alone and it's really
nice to be able to hear how
other people are working.
It's just like, yeah, that
makes me feel really good.
And then feedback.
Feedback, yeah.
[LAUGHS] So feedback.
And this one is definitely
hard, where a big part of--
in this kind of
Creative Curve book
and just in general
design, you actively
are soliciting user feedback
all the time, right?
And that's a huge part of it.
And you cannot be attached
to what you've produced,
essentially.
Like, you have to let the
users tell you what to do.
And I think that that
is extremely hard.
[LAUGHS] Getting
feedback is hard.
And definitely not
something that people
are trained to do, right?
No, yeah.
And then I feel like--
I mean, I don't know.
Maybe it's just curmudgeonly,
because I see it the most.
But I feel like,
especially in academic sets
and in data science
in general, people
do take it really personally.
There's a quote
that I kind of hate
where it's like, photographers
and statisticians both fall
in love with their models.
[LAUGHTER]
I feel bad rep--
but it makes the
point that like--
[LAUGHTER]
You see people like
really dig their heels in.
And it gets personal.
And what I like is that
at least with the user--
I think in the
design field, there's
a lot more focus on
that accepting feedback.
And then also I mean, another
thing kind of personally--
Hilary's personal corner--
of the one thing I
did not expect from starting
this kind of meditation
practice and going down that
path is that, it genuinely
made me better at getting
empathy and getting feedback.
Because essentially
the whole practice,
the whole idea is like
dissociating yourself
from who you think you are.
So it allows you to not
feel personally threatened
if someone challenged--
People take stuff
personally when
it's like your whole identity
is that you're a statistician
and you're smart, right?
And then if someone says
your model is wrong,
it's like, oh, no,
I'm not smart anymore.
My whole identity
is, like, gone.
And then you're defensive.
And so figuring out ways--
and for me, like meditation--
but just figuring out ways
to detach yourself from that
makes you able to take feedback.
And then that actually makes
you better at the thing.
So it's kind of like a paradox.
But it's not like
a magical thing.
It's something that
can be practiced.
Exactly.
So yeah, the thing about
the meditation practice
that was a big
paradigm shift for me
was that these things aren't
just, like, fixed properties.
It's not just like,
oh, this person's
good at getting feedback or
this person has a thick skin
and that's a set character
trait and mine is not
and that's done.
It's like, no, there are
ways to essentially engage
in practice that makes
you more robust to that.
And again, looking at kind of
the neuroscience and Buddhism
stuff, you have
neuroplasticity and you
can make new neural pathways
that make this stuff--
it's not just like,
oh, yeah, I swear.
There are ways that you can
essentially change your brain.
And actually the Nigel Cross
stuff goes into that, of like,
you look at people
who are cab drivers
and their spatial
regions of their brains
are much more developed.
So yeah, doing
creative work is hard.
And it's very different
than doing scientific work.
And it's also what we're doing.
And there are ways
to get good at it.
There's ways to practice it.
There's ways to get good.
Doing this whole podcast--
it's like being OK with
iterating and showing
things that will be wrong
in the future, it's OK.
And actually, it'll
make you better.
And that's kind of
why I feel like I've
wanted to talk so much
about the Design Thinking
is because I want people
to feel empowered to engage
in that part of
honing their craft
and not feeling
intimidated by it.
I think probably a lot
of people in this room
don't think they're creative.
I didn't think I was creative.
And I don't think that I--
yeah, it's just like identity.
It's, like, I'm a scientist.
Hilary does science--
math and science.
And I want people to go through
that same process I went
through of, like, opening
up that side of myself
and being like,
oh, this stuff all
makes me better at this work and
it's more fun, because of it.
And you can do it, too.
Like, anyone can do it.
[LAUGHS]
So anyway.
That was, like, sitcom ending.
There you go.
Except that we do
have one piece--
We have one more.
Yeah, so that was, like,
bigger recurring theme.
We have one more recurring
theme that we are not
open to feedback on.
That's right.
So we have one piece of--
this is the only
data in our whole--
Yeah.
You did make this in R, right?
So we do have R in this talk.
Oh, there is R, yeah.
Yeah.
This is a ggplot, actually.
So we have one more clip.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
Now we're bringing tea time
to the internet, right.
HILARY PARKER
(RECORDING): Exactly.
I don't actually have
tea today, though.
I've also gotten
into coffee now.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING): No!
HILARY PARKER
(RECORDING): I know.
[LAUGHS] Maybe it'll
be coffee time?
Nah.
ROGER PENG (RECORDING):
That doesn't sound right.
So yeah, the lead up to that
was that this podcast, in part,
was we--
I went to grad school where
Roger was a professor.
And we have this tea time thing.
And we had all these
conversations, enjoyed them.
And then it was like,
oh, no, I'm into coffee.
Yes, we can no
longer have tea time.
Yeah.
This is where Hilary switches.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
And it really was
post-grad school, because--
this is a long rant.
You have only two minutes.
Most of my life,
I had bad coffee.
Like, I think we all--
someone was-- the
guy from Australia
was talking about how
it's an experience
to have bad diner coffee.
It's like, oh, you
come to America,
you have burnt diner coffee.
It's so bad, it's good.
Only in America.
Yeah.
So let me just explain on
the x-axis is episode number.
On the y-axis is number of
mentions of the word coffee.
Yeah.
It's good to have transcripts,
so thank you stringr package.
So Hilary switches
tea to coffee.
This is in episode
36 is where I say
people shouldn't talk about
drinking things on podcasts.
Yeah, like you go
on a kind of long rant
about listening to other
podcasts and the fact
that they're talking about
the bourbon they drink.
That's right.
And you were like, that
doesn't belong on a podcast.
Like, you were harsh.
Because I thought you
were saying people
shouldn't actively be
drinking alcohol on a podcast.
And you were like, no,
no, no, but like talking
about the bourbon.
It's really annoying
when people-- yeah, anyway.
Anyway, so since then--
We can't say cause
and effect here,
but the number of
instances has gone up--
Has gone up, yeah.
But literally--
This will be the
hill we die on.
Yeah.
And the last piece of follow-up
is that based on feedback,
I was open to it, I got this
mocha pot to make coffee.
That's right.
And I literally
couldn't give it away.
Like, we had a whole episode--
That's right.
--about if anyone
here wanted it,
I'm willing to give it away.
And no one emailed us.
That's right.
No one wants the mocha pot.
And then last night, we
got some more feedback
about a new device to try.
That's right.
Episode 102, we'll talk about.
So anyway, yeah.
If you don't like
coffee, don't talk to us.
[LAUGHTER]
We're going to keep on going.
Yeah, so anyway-- actually,
I did have a tie-in for this.
I was thinking about it,
where Shop Class as Soulcraft,
where it's kind of like,
you just have to do stuff.
Like, I started
making coffee and then
I wanted to talk about it more.
You know what I mean?
The more that you do
something, you can kind of
fall in love with anything.
And you just have
to do it a bunch.
And you start to care about it.
So again, to the creativity,
just start trying
and you'll start
to like it more.
And you'll start to feel more
empowered to talk about it.
And then you'll bother everyone
around you by talking about it
way too much.
And then--
And then you'll do
a keynote on RStudio.
And then you'll
do a keynote on it.
Anyway, so that's our episode.
Thanks for listening.
Yeah.
And thanks to rstudio::conf
for having us here.
[APPLAUSE]